les premiers soins après l'horreur de la
guerre cette habitante de marioupol a pu
sortir de la ville assiégée elle est
désormais prise en charge dans cet
hôpital de zaporijia dans sa fuite elle
a tout laissé derrière elle
sait pas si ma maison tient toujours
debout si elle a brûlé ou si elle est
même encore là il n'y a plus de
communication c'est devenu impossible de
téléphoner la bannière quitté la ville
au péril de sa vie comme cet homme qui a
perdu sa jambe en voulant se mettre à
l'abri
on s'est arrêté une balle a frappé ma
vitre en sortant de la voiture j'ai posé
le pied sur une mine
vivendi normal on n'a pas demandé à
subir tout ça on ne voulait pas de
quelle liberté poutine par le tilt à
cause de lui j'ai perdu ma
sauvaud d'offres à marioupol 90% de la
ville aurait été détruite d'après les
autorités
certains n'ont nulle part où aller et
vivent au jour le jour sans eau courante
ses habitants font la queue pour remplir
des bidons d'eau potable non loin de là
ces ouvriers déblayent les décombres
d'un bâtiment bombardé avec la crainte
de trouver de nouveaux corps le
président hélène ce qu'il s'est exprimé
devant l'assemblée parlementaire sud
coréenne il évoque un bilan possible de
dizaines de milliers de morts et réclame
une intervention plus forte des
occidentaux
ils ne mangent botnet il n'y a aucune
chance que la russie s'arrête d'abord
sauvé
mais moi il n'y a aucune chance que la
raison dans porte et que les dirigeants
russes refusent tout simplement
poursuivre cette guerre vide maurice
la russie ne peut qu être forcé à le
faire
dans ce champ de ruines qu'est devenu
marioupol une dernière bataille se
prépare d'après l'armée ukrainienne un
assaut final des troupes russes face à
des soldats démunis dans l'incapacité de
tenir plus longtemps le siège
faute de munitions